what's good guys I'm Calvin a I'm the
CDC I win Sun in Brooklyn today Inga
challenged me to do a dollar store
challenge to use ingredients from Daiso
this Japanese dollar store and attempt
to make a two course meal one entree in
one desert let's go if I made it out
here to die so I out in Flushing now
we're gonna look around for some stuff
the a lot of it around you got some
pretty sick plates here for a dollar
store dude this is like Street food
section now is Lee surrounded by food
all over mmm it's like noodle sex
yakisoba flavor
aka msg excusable I love Pocky I
probably in all these flavors
it's good be for dessert almond crunch
hell yeah it's hot and spicy I'm down
there though this is marshmallow it's a
sponge
ooh wasabi peas now let's sabi flavored
but still delicious we'll definitely
some chocolate definite get some protein
up in here for the entree grilled dried
yellow Jack I want to go see food and
then actually got rice and stuff we
could probably do a rice or noodle dish
yes do it a curry noodle Annie I'm gonna
grab a Buddha it was so good I've
actually never used these carries before
but it will rave about these things
all right how hot do you got it some
furikake I'll probably Chazz it up with
a bunch of other snack siga
seaweed-based seasoning with sesame
seeds and much other stuff i love
seaweed snacks i think i'll blitz this
up and I'll be a good little seasoning
mix a little chili oil drizzle on top
let's grab a soy sauce all right so I
think we have the entree covered and
I've go back to thinking about dessert I
love red bean stuff if some of this
baked wheat cake pastry room feel like I
do something with this maybe I could
soak this let's see what drink that
alright I got a little bread pudding
type dessert with milk yeah cuz we don't
have milk take one of these take a
coffee shot milk tea and coffee together
isn't that good just do both they still
love this stuff when I was little we
could use just like the frosting part I
say I think we're pretty sad yeah now
we're back here at the BuzzFeed kitchens
and I'm just gonna do a little recap and
kind of what my plan is an idea I'm sure
it'll change as I go I kind of separated
out into two sections this side will be
dessert and this side will be the entree
I'm trying to do like a little coffee
milk tea bread pudding and on this side
we're gonna
Harry you don with some peas some jerky
and I'll whip up a little season a mix
should be good
I probably start with doing the dessert
first have some time to cook in the oven
I have faith die so never disappoints
this is the baked wheat coffee cake see
what it tastes like
it's okay a little dry we'll make it
work now this is red bean thing has to
be good
it's literally like pancake with like
the sweet red bean filling ooh this is
actually really good the coffee kicked
more neutral so might actually work
really well I broke my everyday knife
just cuz I'm used to using it I'm
familiar with it it's like weird using
it cutting sponge cake but get the job
done gets everything done I'm just gonna
whip up a little batter we didn't get
eggs at Daiso but everyone has eggs at
home right I should try these coffee
drinks too
oh that's sweet it's good Duff a little
bit of this mmm this coffee shot I think
she's just unsweetened straight black
cut that sweetness when the other one is
the milk tea it's like the drink grown
up and like Chinatown bakeries this will
be nice more of that I wink everything
that's what cooking is about swing it
taste it use all your senses and see how
it goes get these bad boys in I'm gonna
soak it up a bit before I chuck it in
the oven you want to be a little
custardy a little butter is a staple
butter makes everything better you know
all up on the sides dude I love butter
it's basically french toast chopped up
in a pan usually I would add like milk
half-and-half or cream or something but
milk tea counts flavored milk even
better get a little chocolate to it
ooh cut them in half so they melt cool
15 20 minutes 350 we'll check it out 17
see we're at we waited for the bread
pudding to cook it'll work on the curry
udon I think I'm gonna do a soft soy
para date egg for that one so I'm gonna
get the eggs cooking for that crank this
thing up only put one on the dish but
I'll cook another in case it cracks her
get hungry I like seven-minute eggs
little Jam here then I'll see what I'm
working with
with this curry I've never used this
before but you said it's good so I trust
you
you picked extra hot too it smells
really good
I want to definitely rehydrate the dried
seafood that we got this is legit just
like whole dried little fishies do you
guys just pretty tasty you don't have to
rehydrate that one Simon that chewy
this is the dried filefish this one shoe
it I'm gonna cut this up in the scripts
and I soaked it up
this one looks weird ooh three different
textures just punchy this will be nice
feel like the top maybe alright so I'm
definitely rehydrate this mile just
throw these bad boys into and then I'll
probably use the liquid as well help
build the berry sauce later this I'll
reserve in another Bowl at that I'll
sort out if we said we were gonna do our
own version of furikake you literally
throw that on anything this one's kind
of citrusy too it's nice and these were
that crispy noodle snack they just like
broken ramen packets delicious little
bit at ha and spicy corn snack yeah I'll
be good
alright eggs are done just hang out
it'll blitz this up and make her own
little Suzy mix for the top little taste
yeah we might get full snack powder so
we got that music glass out see we're
working with with these noodles there's
pretty much fully cooked what we're
doing is reheating these later eggs are
out then peel these up get them in a
little soy sugar mixture if I that's
time the sauce and noodles are done
these will be perfectly marinated good
then we did another this one's busted
proper preparation prevents poor
performance that's the bottle nice Lou
sug
cool let this hang out here as well the
third thing we got besides butter and
eggs or scallions so I'm gonna utilize
the greens for the garnish later and the
white parts gonna treat these as onions
by the time we finish this the bread
pudding should be ready to come out the
oven it's just canola oil I also decided
I'm gonna add these dried vegetables and
rehydrate these a little bit in the pan
this is the packets that came with the
futon and we're gonna throw the peas in
there as well as their vegetables not
enough that these pack is open to more
scallions see if you don't want to cheat
just use these packets then I like four
scallions at this block melt this down
add some peas for help I'm gonna add all
the liquid from rehydrating this fish
that flavor helped built this sauce
better let it reduce other thicken a
little bit taste it Reese's and if we
need to a little more salt cut the heat
add some butter emulsify that in is it a
better mouthfeel one last taste
hopefully it's pretty nice it's not even
that hot nice look this smells pretty
good let this rest finish absorbing all
the liquid it should still be really
custard to you these noodles are hard
cooked so that shouldn't take more than
two three minutes in the water good
little little oil got our sauce that we
made pretty intense and flavor a little
bit should go a long way a little bit of
the udon water help bring this together
[Music]
and then we'll taste it maybe he's a
little more seasoning who's a little
more on the curry one last taste mmm
plate this up
but that's soy egg that we did earlier
just hanging out here a couple of these
wasabi seaweeds
a little bit on top a little heat his
chili oil fish crunchies and then our
seasoning mix it's a little bit on top
over these eggy's scallion tops the main
entree is finished it's squid fish
veggie curry situation now we're gonna
finish up this dessert real quick I'm
just chopping up some of the random
Pocky sticks we bought the Loess all
over for some texture it needs a little
more pink maybe a little strawberry have
I had using so long cool I did say I
wanted to use this frosting couple dads
she is it's a lot of different dried
cons Tritton fish but you don't really
taste it it's more like umami versus
fishy you're amazing well that's it I
hope you guys were inspired by these two
dishes feel free to roll up to dollar
store supermarket die so wherever and
just caught for item ingredients have
fun
[Music]